- I'm back and hanging with the cast
and creators of "Happiest Season" on Hulu.
So we've got Kristen
Stewart, Mackenzie Davis,
(audience clapping)
and Mary Steenburgen on Skype,
and Mary Holland and Clea DuVall
here in the studio with us.
Movie casts can get pretty close,
but how well do the ladies
of "Happiest Season"
really know each other?
It's time to find out with something,
straight out of our high school yearbooks
called "Who's Most Likely".
♪ Who's most likely ♪
(audience clapping)
(Kelly laughing)
- Jesse, that was a good jingle!
Alright, it's pretty simple ladies.
I will ask you, who's most
likely to do something
and you all get to vote
on who that would be.
So first, Mary Holland.
Who's most likely to be the party girl?
- I mean, it's gotta be Mary Steenburgen.
- [Host] Are you serious?
- Hands down, oh yeah.
Mary would host...
- Are you serious, Isabel?
- Oh yeah, yeah.
She is a party animal.
- And Kelly, Kelly, one of these days,
you're gonna be there.
- [Holland] Yes.
- I wanna be there!
And I want pie to be there.
- [Mary] Yeah, yeah.
- That's amazing.
I love that answer.
Wait, what are you talking about?
- She would host
(Kelly laughing)
these incredible game night parties.
I remember there was one.
She had us all over at her apartment,
that she and Ted were staying in
and we played running charades
and it got very intense.
It got very competitive.
(laughs)
And yeah, we had the most fun.
But Mary loves games.
- Yeah, I wanna be
invited to a game night.
I'm just saying.
I'm just inviting myself.
Um and I love
- [Steenburgen] Oh you will be.
- That I did not know you were
gonna be the answer to that.
That's amazing.
All right,
next one's for Clea.
- So who's most likely to solve a puzzle?
- Okay, well, I know that it's not really
Um, it's not really, uh...
You're not supposed to do this,
but I would say maybe, me.
- [Kelly] Oh!
- [Clea] Or Mackenzie or
- Mackenzie!
- Mary also.
- Oh, somebody just said Mackenzie
(Kelly laughs)
- (indistinct) doing a crossword...
- We did crosswords.
We also did a lot of escape rooms.
- [Kelly] Oh my gosh!
I love escape rooms.
- [Clea] You do?
- I have done so many, My band,
We love them.
- We are obsessed.
- [Holland] Obsessed.
- [Kelly] They are so fun.
- And we did every escape room
I think that Pittsburgh had to offer.
(Kelly laughing)
(audience laughing)
- [Clea] It was so much fun, um yeah.
- Are you good at them?
Who's the best at an
escape room in this group?
- I mean, this is gonna contemptuous.
- We all bring our own strengths.
I think we can say everybody
brings something different to this.
- Except for me.
- That is not true, Mary.
- I would still be in there,
in Pittsburgh.
- You did so well
when we did escape room.
And am not just being nice.
- It's such a lie.
- It's such a...
(Kelly laughs)
(guests laughing)
- [Clea] We can offline about
this, but you did great.
You did, you did.
- Wait, there's not one of
you that, like stood out,
Cause I'm gonna tell
you right now, if you...
- [Clea] MacKenzie is trying
to give the correct answer
and no one would let her.
- [Mary] MacKenzie!
- [Kelly] Oh!
- The correct answer is, it's Clea.
- [Clea] Yeah.
- [Mary] It's Clea absolutely.
(Kelly laughing)
(audience laughing)
- Clea was like, she wants to say it.
(Clea laughing)
(guests laughing)
This one is for Kristen,
so who's most likely to
distract everyone on set?
- Uh, Mary, probably.
- [Kelly] Which Mary?
- Oh, uh Steenburgen.
- [Kelly] What! Are you partying so much,
nobody can get anything done?
(guests laughing)
- No, all of us could
focus when Mary was around.
- [Mary] I have a hard time behaving.
- [Kelly] Oh my God, I love you.
- I've done this job too long.
(Kelly laughing)
- I think it's the Southern roots.
That's what it is,
cause I like to have a good time too.
And that's amazing.
I love...
Okay.
And one more, let's go to MacKenzie.
So who's most likely to
drink and play games?
You're gonna say Mary aren't you?
(Kelly laughs)
(guests laugh)
- Well ,maybe, I would say most likely
to drink and play games,
I feel like Kristen and I.
- [Steenburgen] I think,
Yeah, you and Kristen.
- (indistinct) honestly,
everyone actually liked to
hang out with each other
on this movie.
It was fun on set,
but me and MacKenzie were talking about
how surprised we were
at everyone's willingness
to engage all the time.
It was very fun to have so many friends.
- [MacKenzie] Yeah.
- [Steenburgen] Yeah.
- We were like feeling so popular.
Cause we had each other for so long.
I was like,
wow! I have like 10 friends right now.
- Yeah. That's awesome.
I love that y'all had such a good time
and maybe, not you Clea,
you're probably like shut up!
- [Clea] No.
(Kelly laughing)
I had a great time.
I loved all of them so much.
And I...
you know, I really wanted to
play with them and I couldn't.
So sometimes I felt like, you know,
like the kid on the outside be like,
are they playing the game?
Oh, they're playing the game.
- [Kelly] By the way
- And I have to stay here.
I'll set up the shot.
Yeah, I'll set up the shot.
- That's, by the way
that is the exact feeling
of like me touring with
my band for 20 years.
And everybody's like,
Oh my God! So we saw this,
this, this, and like,
I was doing like 17 interviews.
And I was like,
so glad you had such a good time.
- [Holland] Yeah
(laughs)
(guests laughing)
- It's like, cool.
I'm glad.
So it's so fun for you.
I got to talk about myself
for like 11 hours straight,
but anyway, um, we'll edit that out,
So I don't seem so angry.
(guests laughing)
- No keep it,
keep it!
- I don't know, maybe
everyone's feeling it.
Thank you so much to all
of you for being here.
Y'all be sure to watch "Happiest Season".
(audience clapping)
It's starting November 25th on Hulu.
If you wanna laugh,
you gotta watch.